hello wall and hope you had a really fun
st. Patrick's Day and I hope the one you
woke up to this morning was just as
attractive as they were when you went to
bed with them last night all shit-faced
and hammered probably not but we got the
perfect cure for a hangover this morning
we have a new trailer to Ridley Scott's
new movie prometheus so when this new
trailer for Prometheus we find out that
maybe this advanced race of aliens that
might have even put us here wants us to
find them we're all here because of a
map you two kids found in a cave not
somehow an invitation and so we embark
on a Star Trek TM but not for this movie
to go find this advanced civilization
what we find is a lot more than that and
we might all just die because of it so
initially for Prometheus Ridley Scott
was like oh I'm working on a new alien
pretty cool then he's like oh no I'm not
working on an alien pretty well I'm
working on Prometheus this is something
completely different but after seeing
this trailer and the last trailer it's
totally an alien prequel so Prometheus
has a lot of cool stuff going on they
land on this planet know like aw crap we
might all just die now and Earth will be
obliterated then it shows people like
running and people's faces are melting
off and it does that weird sound
it's like the new wow that trailers have
had for the past year and a half but now
it's a couple things though I do feel
like this trailer shows us a lot more
than it probably should we find out all
this ships gonna go to earth to wipe it
out oh hey look at that we showed the
ship crashing the trailer apparently it
doesn't go to earth unless that's a
small part of the plot that case it's ok
we do also in this trailer see this
parasitic life-form it looks like it
gets into the human body and just starts
messing it up I can't shake the thought
that somehow we're responsible for the
aliens in Alien which is almost like a
no does statement because something like
that will probably happen however if
we're really gonna theorize here we go
I think Michael FAAST fenders robot you
know like they had in the first and
second Alien movies you should listen to
the things he says the looks he gives on
his face if he's not an Android he's a
villain big things have small beginnings
and was I the only one who thought of
this when he said that big things have
small beginnings Fassbender famous joke
they they never get old I mean I'll be
honest if Prometheus wasn't an alien
prequel and it wasn't directed by Ridley
Scott I'd be like all right it looks
entertaining but it looks like this
sci-fi horror thing going on that it
looks pretty cool but the fact that it
does have the element of it being an
alien prequel and Ridley Scott directing
it pretty exciting right their movie
looks awesome this is how you make a
prequel you don't force it you make it
part of a larger story
are you listening dude so what are your
theories on Prometheus I want to hear
what you guys think of it how do you
think it's gonna tie into the Alien
movies comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]